a federal judge has just ordered a woman
to pay
$298,000 for burning down Wyoming's only
full service abortion clinic according
to NBC News quote Laura green is already
serving 5 years in prison for burning
Wellspring Health Access weeks before
the clinic was set to open in
2022 but hold on can one really call it
an abortion clinic
if it hadn't opened yet shouldn't the
stage of development at which this woman
aborted the building determine whether
or not her actions constitute a
crime I'm not saying the building could
not one day have become an abortion
clinic it could have it was maybe a
potential abortion clinic but when she
burned it down it was not an abortion
clinic it was just a clump of bricks and
5 years in prison pron seems pretty
steep for damaging a clump of
bricks there are criminals in this
country many criminals actually who
don't even face 5 years in the can for
murder I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
merry Christmas happy New Year good to
be back I can already hear
it some people are going to criticize my
analogy I'm sure Media Matters is
already writing up the hitpiece all the
leftwing outlets they're already writing
it up they're going to say that my
analogy does not hold because when a
woman has an abortion she makes the
choice to end the life of her own child
which they say is her right whereas the
woman who burned down the potential
abortion clinic she burned down someone
else's property over which she has no
rights I hear it I know that this is
going to be the rejoiner but then the
logical followup to that would be are
people
property can can people ever be someone
else's property Democrats say yes
they've said yes to that question a
number of times throughout history but
they're wrong no surprise there breaking
news the libs are wrong not exactly stop
the press's kind of news there's a lot
going on lot going on in this week that
I've been off I tell you I love being
off for a week because I get to see my
beautiful family I get to play with my
cute little kids I I like that and I
know it's good to do that every now and
again but it kills me it pains me not to
do this show I would have come in and
done this show a little bit last week
maybe not every single day but I would I
would have done a little work last week
but out of deference to our beautiful
daily wire staff we didn't we were down
for a week and that means that a lot of
stuff happened during the week Maine
kicked Donald Trump off the ballot we'll
get to that in a second a whole lot of
stuff happened some of which was
surprising some of which was
unsurprising probably the least
surprising news to have happened over
the last week or week and a half is that
on New Year's Eve Green Day do you
remember Green Day they were really
popular
in 2002 and and we haven't heard very
much from them since but they're back
Green Day performed a version of the
only song of theirs that anyone has ever
heard of which is called American Idiot
but in in their new version they swap
out some words to make it an attack on
those magga
[Music]
[Applause]
Americans of
theend
everybody
[Music]
the I
age you hear it they said magga agenda
and and I guess it works because people
are talking about Green Day for the
first time in over 20
years some people are surprised by this
change in part because punk rock has
sometimes had a right-wing flavor to it
wasn't one of the Ramon a big right-wing
Republican and so there's been a it's
unlike all of the rest of popular music
outside of country say it's not totally
left-wing but Green Day has always been
super left-wing there's no big change
here with with Green Day the original
lyrics to American Idiot in that line
that that you just heard where they
changed some of the words was quote well
maybe I'm the America I'm not part of a
redneck agenda now everybody do the
propaganda and sing along to the age of
paranoia and and they just swapped out
redneck for Maga which every single lib
in America identifies as a synonym of
redneck anyway and don't want to be an
American Idiot One Nation controlled by
the media Information Age of Hysteria
it's calling out to idiot America okay
so Green Day hasn't changed they're
still attacking Republicans they're
still attacking right-wingers they're
still attacking the most recent
Republican president but something has
changed this is much more ridiculous in
2023 than it was in 2003 why is that
well
because in 2002 2003 Green Day could be
could pretend to be part of the
opposition they could pretend to be
dissidence you know George W bush is out
here with his redneck Coalition of
Voters that's going to go out and police
the whole world and George Bush controls
the media that was always ridiculous the
so you know Fox News and and the
actually even the New York Times even
the rest of the media did support bush
in the Iraq War they didn't support Bush
most of the time but in the runup to the
Iraq War the entire media were were
pretty much on board with that so they
had a claim in 2002 2003 but what about
today does anybody really believes One
Nation controlled by the media refers to
the right-wing media are you kidding me
the right-wing media have been banned
there there's one social media platform
where the right-wing media are not
heavily suppressed and that would be
Twitter Information Age of Hysteria
Information Age of where's the hysteria
is the hysteria on the right where we're
saying hey guys can maybe can you not
let husky Hank go into the girls
changing room at the public pool with my
daughter hey would you mind can we can
we acknowledge that boys and girls are
different and Nations have borders and
can everyone be normal or is the
hysteria on the left where they're
screeching and screaming that Donald
Trump is Hitler 2.0 and that's why we've
got to kick him off all the ballots and
the only way to save democracy is to
stop the most popular candidate in the
race from from appearing on
ballots who's hysterical it's calling
out to idiot America idiot America okay
some
Americans don't know the difference
between boys and girls okay now I don't
like to call anybody an idiot I
understand there's a lot of confusion in
this Fallen World but if you're going to
call someone an idiot if you're going to
call one ideology in America an idiot
ideology which ideology is it going to
be the ideology that says hey be normal
or the ideology that says Men actually
can be women Green Day hasn't changed at
all too bad that they haven't had they
changed they would appear much less
ridiculous today what has changed is the
political order of the country we need
to restore some balance to that we need
to restore some balance to your body
that's why we need balance of nature
right now go to balanceof nature.com
promo code nolles living a healthy
lifestyle is not easy especially when
you're always on the go you need simple
manageable routines to make sure you're
getting proper nutrition every day which
is why I'm a huge fan of balance of
nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure you
are getting essential nutritional
ingredients balance of nature uses an
advanced cold vacuum process that
encapsulates fruits and vegetables into
Whole Food supplements without
sacrificing their natural antioxidants
the capsules are void of additives
fillers extracts synthetics pesticides
or anything sugar the only thing in
balance of nature fruits and veggies are
fruits and veggies there has never been
an easier way to make sure you're
getting your daily dose of fruits and
vegetables go to balance of.com use
promo code nolles k wle for 35% off your
first order as a preferred customer plus
get a free bottle of fiber and spice
that is balance of nature.com promo code
n kwes for 35% off your first preferred
order plus a free bottle of fiber and
Spice now I haven't even touched on the
biggest controversy of this week off
that we had the it was all anyone could
talk
about it is much more important than any
wars going on overseas much more
important than the migrant Invasion
going on within our borders much more
important than the 2024 election I of
course refer to the bikini
calendar if you have not heard about
this that means you were not on Twitter
during or X now between Christmas and
year the calendar is put out by uh the
guy who has the ultra right beer company
Seth weathers and his brand is America
conservative dads and the the calendar
is conservative dads real women of
America 2024 calendar and it features a
bunch of pretty right-wing gals uh some
of whom perhaps have appeared on this
show and who I'm friends with actually
uh but you know the one on the the cover
is Riley Gaines and a number of other
women are are in the calendar I don't
want to knock the calendar too much
because as I've mentioned I'm friends
with a number of the people involved I
think the big reason why this became a
controversy is because it was a very
quiet news week Christmas was going on
new year is going on people didn't have
that much to bicker about so uh people
bickered about this in part I assume it
was a marketing strategy to sell more
calendars and I assumed it worked very
well because everybody was talking about
it for a while the only reason I bring
up the calendar
the only thing about it that I think is
politically
significant is that I think the
controversy beyond all those other
causes I just mentioned stems from a
conflict a festering conflict that has
gone on for a very very long time but is
really coming to the surface now between
two kinds of
conservatism Boomer conservatism and
Zoomer
conservatism two kinds of conservatism
the conservatism of 15 years ago just
yeah man do whatever you want just don't
make me pay for it let's shrink the
government let's not pay any taxes
Freedom there's that kind of
conservatism and there's the younger
Zoomer conservatism which is hey can we
please have a normal society can we
maybe recall some of the virtues can we
have order can we have normality can
we can can we have a nice flourishing
country in which to live that has
standards and Norms those are very types
of conservatism okay I think you know
where my sympathies lie in this kind of
battle but that's what this battle is it
really has nothing to
do it has very little to do with the
pretty ladies who are posing in the
calendar it has a little bit to do with
the fact that the brand happens to be
conservative dad so even if you're fine
with pretty girls in a calendar you know
the fact that it's being marketed by and
perhaps to fathers who should be married
with women who are married and that kind
kind of creates a little bit of an issue
with it too wouldn't wouldn't
necessarily recommend that but below all
of that the deeper issue going on is a
battle between Russell Kirk and a Rand
who has the soul of the conservative
movement is conservatism about
conserving a way of life and Order and
norms and a a moral sense and maybe a a
Christian religious
tradition or is conservatism just about
Freedom do whatever you not even again
not my view of freedom but Freedom like
you know just go do whatever you want
don't tell me what to do man get out of
here Authority right what is it Russell
Kirk or IR Rand is it Pat Buchanan or is
it George HW Bush that we had this
debate in 1992 what is it is it the
conservatism of normality a way of life
a whole political order or is it let's
get that GDP up
again is is it the conservatism of order
and virtue is it the conservatism of
choice and Lous that's that's the battle
and probably the Calendar's Defenders
would say oh Michael you're making a big
deal out of it I'm not I'm not denying
that this issue was overblown it was
overblown because people were bored over
Christmas no doubt but that political
conflict that the calendar represents
that is very real and that is not
overblown that's that's a conflict that
has been simmering in the so-called
conservative movement going back to
World War II okay going back to the
founding of what is called Capital C
capital M conservative movement
trademark over the T that's been boiling
for a long time which is it going to be
Brent Belle had this argument in the
pages of National Review back when
National Review was the house organ of
the conservative movement said Freedom
or
virtue what does what does freedom even
mean right that's what's going on here
which side is winning well the dominant
side Remains the Boomer side because the
Boomers still wield most of the
political power but the ascendant side
is the Zoomer side the ascendant side is
order and virtue which is fine by me
fine by me now we might need not not
need to worry about what the future of
the conservative movement holds because
conservatives might not hold any
political power if we hold any now we
might not hold it for very long anyway
because Maine has become the second
state to kick Donald Trump off the
ballot in the 2024 primary now you
remember a couple weeks ago Colorado
kicks Trump off the ballot the way
Colorado did that was in a very
contentious decision 4-3 decision by the
Colorado Supreme Court that said that
Trump is a terrible
insurrectionist and that's why they're
going to invoke some never used in this
way pres president of the or
non-precedential
the country well they're going to use it
to kick Trump off the ballot okay now
Maine is going even further it's not the
Maine Supreme
Court it's not it's not a a group of
robed lawyers who are seriously
considering the law and and bringing
their legal scholarship to bear it's
just some democrat politician some total
C whose name is shenna Bellow she's the
main Democrat Secretary of State she is
is seen in photographs buddy buddy with
Joe Biden she visited the White House in
March she visited the White House in
June according to visitor logs she says
that the Electoral College that is to
say the way we do elections in America
is a a relic of white supremacy okay
she's a nut and she's come out and
single-handedly kicked Donald Trump off
the ballot which is even worse than it
sounds because if you're a republican
maybe you don't like Donald Trump but
still you would have to say well look
Donald Trump is the most popular
candidate in the Republican party so now
you've got a Democrat
politician single-handedly kicking off
the presumptive nominee of one of the
two major political parties in the
United States that's crazy but it's even
worse than that because Donald Trump is
not just the most popular Republican
candidate he is the most popular
presidential candidate in the country
by pretty much any measure so if you
look at the real clear politics average
of polls RCP is very good I cite them a
lot because they don't just look at one
poll or this poll and this one's an
outly or maybe this one's not reliable
they look at all the polls and they wait
them according to their reliability and
so you get a much sturdier number here
from RCP and according to
RCP head-to-head Trump over Biden Trump
wins by 2.4 points right now now it
might not just be Trump and Biden don't
forget Bobby Kennedy Jr might be running
right okay what happens if it's Trump
versus Biden versus Bobby Kennedy Jr
Trump wins by one
point beats both of those guys okay
might not just be Bobby Kennedy Jr what
if it's uh Jill Stein the Green Party
candidate what if it's Cornell West who
is a radical leftist Professor from
Princeton I think he was at Harvard for
a while uh is a leftist who kind of
pulls support from Joe Biden and it's
Biden and it's Trump what happens in
that case Trump wins by Five
Points Donald Trump is the most popular
presidential candidate in the United
States by any
measure if a random Democrat
politician can single-handedly take him
off the ballot in a
state in the name of Defending
democracy then what does democracy
mean in that case it doesn't mean
anything democracy is government by the
people if the people are not permitted
to cast their ballot for the most
popular guy then there's no democracy
anymore now Trump Remains the top dog in
the race there was a change over the
over the break though and the change is
that there is another a number two dog
in the race
who we haven't seen before and that
would be Nikki Haley Ronda santis has
been the number two guy in the
Republican race for all of
2023 and he is still the number two guy
he's just the number two guy that's tied
with the number two lady who is Nikki
Haley now people are shocked by this
because people have very strong feelings
about Nikki Haley people who are a
little bit more
Centrist they really like Nikki Haley a
lot of the Republican Consultants really
like Nikki Haley they think that she's
got the best chance to beat Joe Biden
because she appeals to a broader array
of people conservatives often do not
like Nikki Haley they find her to be a
bit establishment a bit Bush era kind of
Republican a little eager to go invade
foreign countries and so they don't like
her and and some of the criticism from
the conservative side of the Republican
party has been intense at Nikki
Haley but when Nikki announced that she
was running in this race you know I hate
to say I told you
so I believe I pointed out that one
should not count out Nikki Haley
everyone was making fun of her she's
going nowhere she has no constituency
her views out are outdated blah blah
blah all this stuff I said you guys
don't know what you're talking about
Nikki Haley is a very very talented
politician she managed think about this
she is one of if not the only politician
in America who has huge establishment
critics
cred who has major cred among the bush
wi of the Republican
Party who did very very well under Trump
she served under Trump she was Trump's
face at the United Nations she was very
popular in that role when she left the
White House Trump basically gave her a
ticker tape parade okay he had that big
press conference sitting with her Nikki
has done a great job we really like her
then she turned on Trump then she turned
back and supported Trump then she kind
of turned on Trump again running against
him and still Trump is saying nice
things about her Nikki is very good at
politics so it is no surprise to me that
entering into 2024 she is now a number
two candidate in the race what we will
wait for this week and next week is can
Nikki kick disantis to number three
right now they tied can she kick him to
number three I would not be surprised as
I said you know I hate to say I told you
so but as I said for a year Dan santis
is great he's really great he's a great
Governor he's terrific I really admire
the guy he's fabulous but part of the
things that are really likable about him
to someone like me are going to make him
unpopular as a candidate because he's a
little too trumpy to attract The
Establishment Centrist folks but he's
not trumpy enough he's not Trump so he's
not going to pull enough of the Trump
voters which means that while he looks
like maybe he's the best candidate in
the race he's also a man without a home
now here at the daily
wire we are taking back the culture
we've got some great things lined up for
you this year like the hilarious Mr
burum daily wire's first ever animated
series featuring an All-Star cast
including Adam Corolla Roseanne Bar
Megan Kelly and more plus the daily wi's
highly anticipated series The Pen Dragon
cycle filming just wrapped right now you
can catch a sneak peek of what's to come
with our incredible Pendragon production
Diaries at dailywire.com and the 2024
election will be one of the most
pivotable pivotable that's a that's a
word that I'm going to coin today it's
one of the most pivotal in our country's
history the election wire is your source
of Truth bringing you everything from
the campaign trail to the debates on
Election Day dailywire Plus members can
now unlock our brand new kids app bent
key at no additional cost where you can
find shows that kids love and parents
trust you will be the first to see Snow
White and the evil queen featuring our
very own Brett Cooper exclusively on m
key in 2024 your daily R Plus Membership
will give you more Ben Shapiro M Walsh
Candace Owens Andrew claven Jordan
Peterson Prager you and most important
of all your favorite podcast Host this
will be the daily wire's biggest year
ever we can't do it without your support
join the fight to reshape and take back
our culture today dailywire.com
subscribe now things are looking good
for Nikki Haley she did get in a little
bit of trouble over the break she was
asked a question on the Civil War of all
things on the campaign Trail and she was
criticized for her answer what was the
cause of the United States Civil
War
well don't come with an easy question or
anything I mean I think the cause of the
Civil War was basically how government
was going to run the freedoms and what
people could and couldn't do what do you
think the cause of the Civil War
was I'm sorry I'm not rning for
president I I I I I wanted to see your
on the cause of the Civil
War I mean I think it always comes down
to the role of government we need to
have capitalism we need to have economic
freedom we need to make sure that we do
all things so that individuals have the
Liberties so that they can have freedom
of speech freedom of religion freedom to
do or be anything they want to be
without government getting in the way
thank you and then in the year 2023 it's
astonishing to me that you answer that
question without mentioning the word
slavery what do you want me to say about
slavery no um uh you've answered my
question thank you
next
question obviously this questioner here
is trying to trip up Nikki Haley I don't
know if it's a Democrat plant probably
it is it could be a plant from one of
the other Republican campaigns or I
guess it could be just a person who
doesn't like Nikki Haley very much uh
for personal reasons
but what's astonishing about the
question and the answer is it's not the
question and it's not the answer it's
the apparent belief on the part of the
questioner and maybe on the part of
Nikki Haley that slavery is a wedge
issue in the Republican party that's
what this is about the questioner asks
the question because he thinks that any
way Nikki Haley answers is going to
alienate some of her voters if she says
that the Civil War is about State's
rights then she's going to alienate
voters who are anti-slavery you know
that the anti-slavery faction of a
Republican Party but that if she says
that the Civil War was about slavery
she's going to alienate that huge
pro-slavery portion of the Republican
party and so haha we've got a great
wedge issue here not surprised that
Democrats think that they they think all
sorts of nasty things about Republicans
that aren't true
Nikki appears
to think that there's some portion of of
Republicans who don't want to hear about
slavery now I actually think that her
answer was almost fine everyone was
saying it's catastrophic it's the end of
her career it's the worst answer I think
the answer was basically fine because
the true answer to what was the Civil
War about is yeah it was about all those
things you know it was about the
political power of the south in the
federal government Abraham Lincoln was
able to win the presidency without the
South meaning the South no longer had
much of a say at all in the federal
government which might be reason enough
if you think of the South as a a
distinct political entity totally
distinct from the north might be reason
enough to impel you to seced and also
what was the hottest issue of the time
that had taken over the country that had
dictated so much of the politics of
Westward Expansion it was slavery no
question about that so yeah it was both
of those
things and furthermore I don't think
that there are very many proslavery
Republicans I don't think there are any
actually I I I think as we mentioned at
the top of this show that there are many
Democrats who support the the logic of
slavery the premises of slavery the
notion that you can own another person
you see the Democrats I'm not even just
making some point about Democrats or
they're true racists or it was the
Democrats who owned all the slaves or
kind of talking points we've heard in
the past I'm making a point about the
politics of today Democrats today are
arguing that if you have a child that
you have full property rights over that
child and you can kill that child if you
want if it's convenient for you
that's what I'm saying that's the logic
of
abortion or even more than that the Lo
it's the logic of IVF and surrogacy the
notion that if you have if you have a
child or you even have the potential to
make a child that that you have total
property rights and you can order your
child out of a
catalog and if you don't like the way
the child comes out then you can order
the child to be killed in the womb of
your surrogate who you also paid for
we've seen stories about that I gave a
long speech about that just about a
month ago you catch that on the yaf
YouTube channel so I'm saying the the
logic of
today the the the policies argued today
by the
parties I if if in any way it touches on
the logic of slavery it's coming from
the Democrats not the
Republicans and it's silly that this
Democrat questioner this this anti-h
haly questioner thought it was a
republican thing but it should be a
wakeup call to the haly
campaign that Nikki stumbled on the
question too I think you could say both
of those things and move on and she did
move on that was very smart of her I
don't think it's really going to hurt
her it's not there are way worse gaps on
a campaign Trail than this but you
know I don't
think I I think if you fall into the
error of believing there's a big
pro-slavery portion of the Republican
party it's because you've just believed
the Democrat propaganda that has been
crammed down our throats for the past 50
years now another smart thing the haly
campaign is doing she's promising to
Pardon Trump if Trump is convicted of
crimes so Haley came out she said a
leader needs to think about what is in
the best interests of the country what
is in the best interest of the country
is not to have an 80-year-old man
sitting in jail that continues to divide
our country what is in the best interest
of our country is to Pardon him so that
we as a can move on as a country and no
longer talk about him so she's still got
a a properly anti-trump tone to this
she's running against him she she's
she's got to be opposing him but the
substance of what she's saying is yeah
I'll pardon him as well she should as
well as all of the Republican candidates
should promise to do they the only
reason that the Democrats are going
after this guy is because he was an
effective conservative he's the most
effective conservative president of our
lifetimes even if you hate his guts and
his tweets and his face and his demeanor
and everything about him you have to
admit that I think the guy got roie Wade
overruled he's he is the first
Republican president
maybe ever first Republican president in
probably about a hundred years to make
Mass migration a major political issue
and do anything to try to stem the tide
of that he's the first Republican
politician in well over quarter no over
probably half a century now to focus on
America's national interest in explicit
terms against globalism and Global
liberalism liberal Empire he's he he's
really he was pretty good you know he
had some flaws but he was pretty good
and the only reason the libs are going
after him is not because he led an
Insurrection or whatever the Liberals
have led many more serious Insurrection
insurrections on the capital that have
actually killed people not just their
own supporters killed members of
Congress killed all sorts of people
blown up parts of the capital many many
times over the years we never heard
Insurrection then Donald Trump disputed
the results of an election that was
obviously
rigged Democrats have been denying the
results of elections of of most
elections that they lose at the national
level and of State national prominence
for a long time the 200000 election the
Stacy Abrams non-election in Georgia a
lot of them even the 2004 election Bush
versus kry the only reason they're going
after him is because he was an effective
conservative I want to hear every
Republican candidate saying yes of
course we'll pardon Trump if I don't
hear that I understand you're running
against Trump you don't like the guy you
want to knock him down but if I don't
hear that then I it makes me think
you're on the other team if I he well
you know if the Democrats discover that
Donald Trump actually did commit a crime
that that makes me think all right
you're you're a lib you know you're a
Democrat shill if you can't acknowledge
the Injustice of what they're doing to
Trump while still effectively running
against him then you're not you're not
it man and you're not it
now does this mean that Nikki Haley is
cozying up to Donald Trump a little bit
here maybe maybe and Trump says some
nice things about Haley too does this
mean that Haley's strategy is get
stronger stronger stronger displace
disantis as the number two candidate
Vanquish V I guess Chris Christie is
still running but forget about Chris
Christie he'll he'll endorse Nikki Haley
and then try to have a Unity ticket like
a Reagan Bush 1980 sort of ticket Trump
Haley then the question that comes from
that is will the Trump supporters
tolerate a Nikki Haley VP pick that I
don't know
because fairly or unfairly the perceived
political vision of trump and Haley is
quite
different the the way that their
supporters perceive their
candidacies very different on the Trump
side of things it's people like Tucker
okay it's people who want fewer foreign
entanglements who want a a more intense
focus on The American Nation who don't
want to
just give money to Chamber of Commerce
like candidates to focus on economics
above
all the Haley candidates tend to be a
little bit more Centrist they tend to be
a little bit more Wall Street donor
types they tend to be a little uh
happier with foreign entanglements
especially in the Middle East are Trump
voters going to tolerate a Hal BP that
remains to be seen speaking of foreign
entanglements a good report out of
Politico over the week it's good it's a
good report but it's frustrating the
report is that the Biden Administration
is subtly quietly shifting strategy on
Ukraine this from Politico for two years
Biden and zalinsky have been focused on
driving Russia from Ukraine now
Washington is discussing a move to a
more defensive posture quote with us and
European Aid to Ukraine now in serious
Jeopardy the Biden Administration and
European officials are quietly shifting
their focus from supporting Ukraine's
goal of total victory over Russia to
improving it position in an eventual
negotiation to end the war according to
a Biden Administration official and
European Diplomat based in Washington
such a negotiation would likely mean
giving up parts of Ukraine to Russia
here we go and the way you know that
this isn't just some random leak coming
out of the White House or a bunch of
smoke being blown is that you're seeing
the same kind of language being echoed
in the other state media organs New York
Times
headline uh this is in an opinion piece
headline Ukraine doesn't need need all
its territory to defeat
Putin and who wrote this uped this was
Serge schmon who is a member of the New
York Times editorial board Ukraine oh
Ukraine doesn't need all of its
territory to to defeat Putin who invaded
and this whole war is about Ukraine's
territory but it's not you don't need
all the territory that's a pretty big
change that's a pretty big change
because some of
us have argued this point from day
one and for that we were called Putin
Stooges and we were called useful idiots
and we were called all sorts of nasty
things anti-American undemocratic you
support fascist dictators and oh hold on
now now that opinion for which we were
all pillared as Putin idiot
Stooges non non-
Patriots that is now the opinion of both
major political parties in the United
States
why because what's the alternative
Ukraine is not going to beat Russia that
can't
happen UK you on its own the war would
have been over in 24 hours but because
the US was actually fighting Russia here
through this proxy of Ukraine because we
were funding the whole War because we
were sending all the arms and and maybe
some people to help fight the war it it
is dragged on now for quite a
while but it was never going to be
enough unless the United States got
directly involved so that means that the
other alternative would be a World
War we avoided it for the entirety of
the Cold War but now we're going to
decide that the U us as the superpower
in the world China's Rising but we
Remain the global hedgemon we're going
to go in and engage in a direct war with
a nuclear former superpower in Russia
and we're going to do this over the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine the
territory of which has changed about a
bazillion times over the last thousand
years which is roughly how long this
conflict is going on does that make a
lot of sense that didn't make sense to
me so what happened we are
now totally Vindicated those of us who
said that this was a bad war that was
that was egged on by the US and by NATO
I'm not the only one to say it Henry
Kissinger said it Sam nun said it George
Kennan implied it the author of The Long
Telegram the architect of American Cold
War policy Daniel Patrick moan said it a
lot of very serious American statement
have said this for a very long time and
we were completely right you know how
much it pains me to say it we were
totally right and now we are exactly
where we were at the very outbreak of
this war except that now because the
Democrats and the establishment
Republican types got their way at least
30,000 ukrainians have been killed so at
least we got that we have we got no
strategic Advantage whatsoever we got no
difference to the way the war is going
to end but hey at the very least tens of
thousands of ukrainians are dead that's
it and these are the Geniuses by the way
these are the grand strategist
these are the guys who say the adults
have got to be back in charge we can't
let those unwashed crazy populists those
right Wingers take over okay well had
the right- Wingers been running the show
had those crazy awful nationalist
populist types been running the
show show me how we would have been any
worse off I don't really see
it my favorite comment this would have
been what a week ago now more than a
week ago is from heon James 2545 who
says oh wow man talk about providential
the the comment actually ties in exactly
with what I just said all nature is but
Ard unknown to thee comment is isn't
everyone glad that the adults are back
in charge it just warms my heart that
Caligula Biden is running the show yes
it does doesn't it speaking of grand
strategy big breaking news oh this is
good court
documents naming Jeffrey Epstein's
Associates to be unse Feld here's what
to know this is from NBC News ABC
News all the newses are reporting this
but I got NBC right here what I love
about this headline they send out the
headline everyone goes crazy and I had
this
prediction look it could still be proven
wrong but my
prediction before the year ended was
we're not really going to get the
Epstein Client List we're not going to
find out new people okay and then 5
Seconds through this headline they're
going to unseal the Epstein Client List
I said oh wow man maybe I was totally
proven wrong that was fast that's the
fastest I've ever been proven wrong
huh but hold on here's the headline
court documents naming Jeffrey 's
Associates to be unsealed what to know
subheader former President Clinton
Prince Andrew and others are expected to
be named hold
on we we know that Bill Clinton was an
Epstein associate
we've known that for the better part of
10 years okay we we we've seen his name
on the flight logs we've seen pictures
of Bill Clinton with Jeffrey Epstein we
know that je that Bill Clinton flew all
around the world with Jeffrey Epstein on
the low lead
Express that he would when he wasn't
flying with Epstein is because he was
borrowing his
plane I don't need to find out that Bill
Clinton is an EP associate prince Andrew
prince Andrew lost his job working for
his mom because we all know that he he
hung out with Epstein we have pictures
of of prince Andrew with Jeffrey Epstein
we have court settlements where prince
Andrew has paid Jeffrey Epstein's former
young ladies okay we I don't I don't
need to hear about that I want to hear
about the end others that's what I want
to hear
about I don't want the names that we
already know that's that's called a
limited hangout okay that is it's a term
that in intelligence circles and crisis
communication circles
where you're caught you're up against a
wall they got you dead to rights you've
been lying you've been lying you've been
denying you've been denying and now you
say okay what are we going to do I'm
going to give them something and so what
you do is you only give a little bit you
and in this case You' be giving
something that everyone already knows
yeah we already know that Bill Clinton
hung out with Jeffrey Epstein oh did did
Bill Gates hang out with him too yeah we
got pictures of that
also I don't want to hear about those
guys I mean I'll hear more I guess but I
want to hear about the guys that I
haven't heard about yet that's the first
thing I want G give us the real Epstein
Client List the names we haven't heard
more than that though the the question
that I want to know the answer to with
regard to Jeffrey Epstein
is who was he working
for nothing about Jeffrey Epstein's life
really adds up very shady past he's got
this business associat SL romantic
partner whose father was mobbed up with
at least three intelligence agencies
around the world we know he was mobbed
up with British intelligence maybe
Russian intelligence and certainly
Israeli intelligence
okay we know that Jeffrey Epstein was
mobbed up with intelligence we know this
from Alex aasta who was us attorney
Prosecuting Jeffrey Epstein in Florida
who then was up for labor secretary
under Donald Trump and reportedly in his
interview when he was asked about the
Epstein prosecution he said I was
told not to really go too hard after
Epstein because Epstein quote belonged
to intelligence what intelligence I
don't know is all of that fake is that
all just fake news and weird
coincidences with gilain Maxwell's
Father Robert Maxwell uh maybe but I
want to
know was was Jeffrey
Epstein rigging up his properties to
record people engaging in weird illegal
sex stuff with underage
girls just to enrich Jeffrey Epstein
look maybe he was just a con artist a
blackmail artist who was shaking down
these rich guys to enrich himself could
be was this part of an intelligence
operation if so which intelligence was
he working for foreign
intelligence MI6 Israel
Russia or was he working for American
intelligence or was he working for lots
of different type of intell but I want
to know less about the scintilating
little details of who did what with whom
uh in terms of what was going on in
those massage rooms I want to know who
did what with whom with regard to what
was this operation
for you know a thing by what it's for
what was this for what was what was the
Epstein weird sex Island and the pen
houses and the video cameras what was
that all in service
of speaking of weird sex stuff another
day another Republican disappoints you
Ohio Governor Mike
dwine has just vetoed a bill Banning
boys from girls
Sports seems like the kind of Bill that
should be a no-brainer right boys being
different from girls should not compete
against the girls and girls Sports which
only exist so that girls have their own
places to compete because they can't
beat
boys Mike dwine doesn't seem to get that
he vetoed a bill on December
29th that would protect these kids from
the
[Music]
the this guy might have good
intentions the road to hell you will
recall is paved with good intentions and
what's wrong about this here is is the
the ethical principle that led dwine to
come to this decision which is an ends
justify the means morality it's
consequentialist thinking to use a more
technical term term it's the idea that
you make moral decisions based on the
outcome that you think is going to occur
rather than the goodness of the actions
themselves or the The Virtue and the
character of one who would make those
decisions good judgment
Prudence there is is leftist thinking
because people when they try to predict
the
consequences they usually get them
wrong and two
because actions are moral or immoral
character are good or bad
okay you're not going to live a good
life by doing lots of bad things you're
not going to have a good
country a a good outcome for your
country by doing lots of individual
really really bad things you're not
going to flourish individually or
politically by lying all the time you're
not going to flourish individually or
politically by denying reality well if
we just deny the most basic aspects of
biolog ological reality of of of human
reality then somehow secretly with all
through a magical procedure we're going
to end up with a really good country I
don't think so I think people who lie to
themselves and Nations that lie to
themselves they fail it's reality
reasserts itself in the end the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it Tuesday actually become a member
use code NCW has so check out for two
months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
oh